hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
welcome to her ultimate camera
comparison between the 1 plus 7 Pro
pixel 3 a galaxy s 10 plus an iPhone 10s
max if you haven't already go down and
smash that like button
seriously guys it only takes a second
and it helps us out a lot so let's get
right into the comparison in this
extreme HDR selfie photo both the pixel
3a and Tenace max seem a little bit
underexposed and the 1 plus 7 pro is the
only one that gets the white balance
spot on but it doesn't have as much
detail as the s10 plus so I'm giving
this one to the Samsung and this one the
pixel 3a has some pretty harsh shadows
and the s10 plus looks to be a bit too
cool on the white balance the 10s max
looks really detailed in this photo but
due to the clouds being so blown out
this one's going to the 1 plus 7 Pro
moving to the rear side both the 7 Pro
and Tenace max look a bit dull and flat
and while the s10 plus looks very
detailed it's looking a bit dark and
lacking highlights the pixel 3 a look
the closest to real life and if we crop
in we can easily see that the s 10 plus
has the most detail out of these phones
in this portrait photo we see that same
detail shining on the Samsung with a
pixel 3 a right behind it however the
pixels white balance is way too cool you
can see that the S 10 plus uses the
regular lens instead of the telephoto
lens for portraits the 1 plus looks a
bit blurry or lacking detail and the 10s
max gives us a nice balanced photo we
see the same exact thing in this photo
for the 1 plus 7 Pro so what may be due
to noise reduction or a low shutter
speed the pixel 3a is way too blue once
again and the sn+ is really smoothing
out the detail in the face we'll go for
the tennis max again for this one we
also notice that you can't adjust the
blur on the 1 + 7 pro and the tennis max
blurs out the t-shirt which looks a bit
weird but is actually realistic now
here's a very tough HDR photo the sn+
does the best at keeping the details in
the sky and we actually noticed a lot of
detail in the hills and trees in the
background and that's because it has
dual apertures so it's shooting at f/2
point 4 instead of around F 1 point 7
with the others and the tennis max has
some very distracting lens flare going
on if we take a closer look the pixel 3a
actually does the best job at properly
exposing in this photo the sn+ over
exposes by a good amount
making the sweater look faded just like
the 1 plus 7 Pro looks without over
exposing it just looks a bit dull the
pixel 3a looks the best overall with
great detail and colors in this portrait
blur photo the 1 + 7 Pro actually does
the best at edge detection with the
other phones struggling with a few areas
here and there in this macro shot the
flowers were blowing in the wind
so the phone's had to freeze the motion
to get good detail in the pixel 3/8 did
the best at this although the tennis max
doesn't look as detailed because of lack
of contrast I really liked how it
exposed the image this photo was shot at
maximum zoom and we can see that the
pixel 3/8 can't zoom in that far since
is the only one that has a single rear
camera and because of that you lose a
lot of detail the tennis max did pretty
well but it's lacking contrast and the s
10 + is the clear winner in terms of
detail although the colors are
oversaturated in this macro shot we
tested minimum focus distance and the
sm+ was able to get the closest and it's
the most detailed as well with the pixel
3a right behind it part of this tree was
in direct sunlight so it was interesting
to see how each phone dealt with it the
tennis max was really flat and the 7 pro
in pixel 3a crushed the detail in the
shadows the s 10 + again has the most
detailed camera - of these photos are
shot using an ultra wide lens with the 7
pro and the s 10 + and it's interesting
to see how saturated the s 10 + makes
this photo but it still looks great
compared to the rest one thing I also
noticed was that the 1 + 7 pro's ultra
wide camera really lacks detail compared
to the s 10 + it's a night and day
difference you can see here that details
are smeared and the sky is completely
blown out the SN + has an excellent job
at this and you can see a lot of blue in
the sky switching to the regular lenses
the pixel 3a actually looks the most
detailed here followed by the 10s max
for some reason the sn+ looked a bit
faded with the least amount of detail on
the 7 Pro this is another tough HDR
scene and we can see that the pixel 3 a
blew out a lot of the clouds and
underexposed the grass the tennis max
chose to expose the scene very well but
blew out all the cloud detail the 7 Pro
does a decent job but the sky looks grey
almost like they brought the highlights
down more than they needed to and
here's the ultra wide versions of these
photos showing that same difference in
ultra wide camera detail in this one it
was up to each phone to freeze the
motion of the spinning tire to capture a
detailed image in the pixel 3:8 again
did the best at it shooting at a higher
shutter speed making for a great-looking
image and we tested the same thing here
with the pixel 3 a giving a very
detailed image followed by the tennis
max then the sn+ and the very blurry
looking 1 plus 7 Pro this photo was shot
testing shutter lag hitting the shutter
button as soon as little Elan got to the
closest point to the camera the tennis
max features zero shutter lag so was
basically instant followed by the s10
plus then the 1 plus 7 Pro and the pixel
3a which takes quite a while to snap a
photo after you hit the shutter button
this one was shot in the shade with a
bright sky and lake in the background
the tennis max was really dark and while
the sn+ looked really good his face is
really orange here due to over
saturation the 1 plus 7 Pro lacked quite
a bit of detail and the pixel 3/8 did
the best overall in this photo the sn+
looked way more detailed compared to the
rest and the sand was actually exposed
very nicely at the same time so I'm
giving it to the s10 plus however in
this sunset cast shot its oversaturated
and the water looks way too green the
oneplus lacked detail and the tennis max
was a bit too cool so this one goes to
the pixel 3a for looking the most true
to life this scene was very tough since
the Sandy Beach is completely in the
shade with direct sunlight hitting the
buildings in the background the sn+ over
saturates quite a bit and the building
on the 7 Pro is a bit low now the tennis
max looks great but it's lacking some
contrast so this goes to the pixel 3a
now soo mning in 3 times we see the same
results here except that the pixel 3a
loses detail since it lacks a telephoto
lens giving the win to the tennis max
now at maximum zoom the pixel 3a looks
very pasty and the sn+ is over
sharpening a lot of the details the
tennis max looks pretty good but there's
a lot of noise especially in the clouds
so this one goes to the 1 plus 7 Pro
here's another one at maximum
the tennis max again has a bunch of
noise and the pixel 3a just looks
terrible
although the s10 plus looks to be more
detailed if we crop in we can see that
it's due to over sharpening the one plus
seven Pro actually has more detail it's
just lacking some contrast in this food
photo the sn+ looks really good but it
just over saturates the colors leading
me to choose the pixel 3a despite the
cooler white balance here's a dark
indoor photo with some bright details in
the background if you look at the
texture in the couch you'll see that the
7 pro and s10 plus are adding a ton of
noise reduction smoothing out the
details the pixel 3a looks great but
it's way too cool in terms of white
balance with the 10s max being very
accurate to what it actually looked like
finally we took a nighttime photo using
nitesite on every phone except for the
tennis max which doesn't have one
although the pixel 3/8 oversaturated the
colors a bit it still looked the best
overall being able to properly expose
the shadows and highlights without
introducing much noise at all the 7 Pro
did a pretty good job as well but it was
a bit too dark so as you guys saw from
the testing the pixel 3a and the Galaxy
S 10 class were better than the iPhone
10's Max and the oneplus 7 pro quite
often the tennis max did very well but
it generally lacked contrast making it
look less detailed than the other phones
the oneplus 7 pro did pretty well but it
generally lacked detailed compared to
the others and the highlights looked a
little bit grey like they turned them
down too much much more than you'd be
able to recover highlight detail and
that leads to the photos looking a
little bit dull and lacking contrast the
pixel 3 age did an excellent job except
the white balance was a little bit iffy
it wasn't consistent and sometimes there
was a little bit too much contrast the
galaxy s 10 plus did an excellent job
except sometimes it was oversaturated
and just ruined the look of the photo
so who's the winner well it's up to you
guys let us know in the comments section
below which phone you think did the best
and if you haven't already hit that like
button hit that like button right now
and click that button above to subscribe
and check out those other videos right
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]